Well, good morning again, church.
It's great to see you. Happy Father's Day.
Uh, my prayer on a day like this is that, uh, a day
of celebration would merely challenge all of us men to
towards holiness, towards Christlikeness, uh, as we lead
and serve others.
This summer, it maybe you are aware,
but if not this summer,
we're spending our Sunday mornings in the book of Romans,
specifically in chapter 12 as we look at
how God realigns our lives back to
the way Christ modeled a life that we should be living.
Uh, as we get into it today, I want to tell you about one
of my favorite movies of all time.
It is the movie Inside Out.
And uh, some of you are like, it's a kids movie.
Yeah, I know you can laugh at me all you want, but,
but I think it's profound, right?
I think this movie is so deep.
Uh, it gives a pretty good picture of
what goes on in our brains every day of our lives.
Now, when it came out, our boys were six, four and one
and a half at the time.
And so it was first released, Emily
and I, my wife, we went out and saw it in the theaters.
Now, if you know the story, you know, that uh,
this family moves
and this, this daughter has to go
through all the emotions of that.
And so we're sitting there
having just moved from Weatherford to Fort Worth,
and we're sitting there regretting our life choices,
just thinking that we've ruined our kids' lives.
We're openly weeping in the theater.
Just, it's a travesty, right?
It was horrible to watch
that movie at that moment in our lives.
Uh, but one of the characters in the film
is Joy.
That's the emotion character named Joy.
And she's usually the one trying
to keep everybody else on track, trying
to keep everybody in the same
direction in those kind of ways.
And yet we discover she's often misguided in her actions.
She's misunderstanding
how the world is working as she goes forward.
Because at times she denies reality.
There's a, there's a fake kind of joy
that she presents throughout the movie
and she tries to cover what's really happening
with this just overabundance of peppiness,
like just denying reality.
Like, no, no, no, we're all gonna be okay.
It's all gonna be fine. No, no, no. Don't, don't go.
Don't get sad. Don't get depressed. Like this is not okay.
We gotta be happy.
Well, listen, that's not the kind of joy
we're talking about today.
The joy we're talking about today is a deep seated,
deep rooted, solid foundation kind of joy.
Something that's not dependent on circumstances,
but dependent on certainty.
And here's why this is so important today, because you
and I are often told
or at least expected to be like joy from the movie,
like we are to present this front, we're
to put on a face because that's just expected of us.
That just like another movie, everything is awesome.
We gotta act like it is.
Nobody can have anything said, you got, it.
Doesn't matter what's going on behind the curtain
of your life, that it's a really hard situation.
You have to act like it's all okay, that's the temptation.
Or maybe even the explicit expectation in our world.
Or maybe this is important for you today
because you just aren't that joyful.
Like you have a pretty sour outlook on the world
for whatever reason.
And, and really, honestly,
you're just kind of hard to be around.
This is so important today
because the Bible commands us to rejoice.
And, and the command to rejoice in the Bible is
above circumstances.
It is grounded in hope, not circumstance, grounded in hope.
And because of that hope, it is then reasonable
to rejoice because of the hope.
This is one of the major marks of what it means to be
a follower of Christ.
This idea of joy, it's a fruit of the spirit,
but it, it's clearly marked out as one of the things we need
to be pursuing.
And so let's just start by praying.
'cause I know not all of you
walked in here, are really joyful.
And so let's start by praying for joy in the Lord.
Wherever your walk is with him today, let's pray
for joy in him.
So God, we do come to you humbly now asking you
and needing you to by your spirit, those
who are believers in this room, by your spirit, infuse
a level of joy that we maybe have never seen
or maybe needed again, from where we're at in life,
not just emotional happiness, but but a deep joy in you.
God, show us what that means through your word today
and make it a reality in us for your glory, for our good,
for the world's good as we'll see in in Jesus' name, amen.
So as we're walking through Romans 12,
we're taking it not just verse by verse,
we're actually taking it phrase by phrase
and looking, examining it, what a life transformed
by Christ looks like.
And remember that we're looking at Christ as the standard
by which we measure everything like our walk with him,
we align with him, we measure our lives off of him.
We don't compare ourselves to the world
or to any other standard
because yeah, we could compare ourselves to somebody else,
but, but that means we're still off
or compare ourselves to the way of the world,
but it means we're still off.
No, we have to go back to comparing ourselves to Christ
and then realigning ourselves back to
him more closely every day.
And that's what we're doing in this series.
And today specifically,
we're studying just the first three words
of Romans 12, verse 12.
They'll be on your notes, they're on the app,
they're on the screen, but it's just the three, the phrase
rejoice in hope.
That's it. Verse 12, the first three words, rejoice in hope.
And again, he's talking to those who believe in Christ.
He's talking to those who've been born again
through the life, death, and resurrection of Jesus.
Those who have been experiencing this reality of,
of offering themselves as living sacrifices to God.
And they've, they've seen that.
That's what's now transforming them.
And this then is one of the main markers of what it means
to be a Christian, to rejoice in hope.
This idea of being joyful, that your life is marked
by a deep rooted joy because of your God.
And so as we get into this, look first
where this command is grounded, notice first
where this command is grounded.
It's dependent on hope here, not on happiness.
It's grounded in hope, not happiness.
And what is happiness? Well, happiness is
that circumstances in your life feel good.
Just think about it. So your,
your good friends throw you a birthday party, you're happy,
you get a raise at work, you're happy, you
see your health improve, you're happy.
The thunder, wind, you're happy, you get a new puppy,
you're happy, right?
Like some of you look at that.
I'm like, just happy because you see the picture, right?
That's the way it is.
Here's the problem with happiness based joy though.
If your happiness depends on happenings, then
it is circumstantial.
It's it's dependent on circumstances that are at times
outside of your control.
And so here's the problem, like, like you, you see
circumstances change and you had nothing to do with it.
But if you're dependent on that for happiness,
then it would fade.
Now let me be clear as we go into this that circumstances
can be appropriate sources of gratitude
and joy like getting married
or becoming a father or being able to be generous
and to help someone financially.
Those are gifts from the Lord and those are circumstances.
So it's not wrong to rejoice in those good gifts
as you see 'em from that good gifts from God.
They just can't be the final hope.
'cause think about how quickly those things can be taken
away from you, how quickly those things can change.
They're good gifts from God. Rejoice, don't get sad.
Don't be sorry about having good gifts from God,
but don't let that be the ultimate hope.
You need more stability.
That's why the superior foundation is hope not happiness.
And when you hear the word hope in our world that is often
construed like wishful thinking,
like I hope the thunder wind tomorrow night.
Well, that's just a wishful thing. We have no idea.
And so we hope in something,
but it's not wishful thinking in the biblical sense of hope.
Hope is confident expectation in God's promises.
It's what Hebrews 11 says Verse one,
faith is the assurance of things hoped for.
The conviction of things not seen.
Like you see how it ties hope
and faith, conviction, assurance,
it ties all of that together.
That hope is not just, well, I hope that happens.
Hope is like, no, this is what I know.
This is something that's going to be certain.
There's a steadfastness to it. Things that we know for sure.
What do we know for sure?
It's the unshakeable foundation
of Christ's finished work for us.
We know, we know that has happened.
Christian hope rests on that, that God
promised a redeemer, God delivered a redeemer doing
everything that was necessary to accomplish our salvation.
That's where our hope rests. That's where our hope lies.
It's not changeable that
because of what Jesus did,
we will one day also be freed from all the sufferings.
This present time brings us Jesus resurrected
so we will be resurrected.
That's what Romans eight says.
It connects our hope to things not yet seen
but still just as certain in God's plan.
That's what Romans 8 24
and 25 says, for in this hope we were saved.
Now, hope that is seen is not hope for
who hopes for what he sees.
But if we hope for what we do not see, we wait for it
with patience.
It's saying we can act as if it's already happened.
We are looking forward to something that we can't see yet,
but we're confident in it anyway.
And so here's what happens
because this command
to rejoice is grounded in hope, not in circumstances.
That means when circumstances in your life threaten
to crush you, hope is what sustains you.
When your feelings fail you
and you don't see a way out hope
endures through that.
When the future looks dark, hope
sees the glory that is coming in Jesus Christ.
See, it looks past what you can see
to a guarantee in the future.
And see, that's why listen, that's why
because of the substance of this solid hope,
because of what it is, that's then
what makes our rejoicing reasonable
because of what it contains, because of what it is.
That's what makes our rejoicing reasonable, normal expected.
Like this is what we do
because the content of our hope in Christ is such as it is.
It makes us rejoicing
as natural 'cause.
Just think about where our hope rests.
Our hope is not in some fickle, some some temporary thing.
Our hope rests what makes up our hope.
Our hope rests in things like this.
One Corinthians 15 says that just
as Christ has been raised from the dead,
those in him will also be made eternally alive.
One day like
because Jesus resurrected 2000 years ago,
we in him will one day be resurrected eternally
as well, guaranteed.
Romans eight verse 30, it guarantees our glorification,
meaning that moment we're made holy, made perfect,
made whole before God.
That day we see him face to face.
It's as if it has already happened.
Justification, sanctification, glorification.
It's as if it's all already happened.
It's that guaranteed you have one
Peter one, three
and four shares about this certain future
inheritance in heaven that is kept by God for you.
It's a certain inheritance coming in the future.
One Peter said that second Peter three 13 reminds us
of God's promise of a new heavens
and new earth that is coming, that's full of righteousness.
It dwells there. That means all
of creation is gonna be transformed.
This is not all there is
and it's coming in the future.
So you take all that together here. Here's the point.
You take all that together, the magnitude
of what awaits us, dwarfs
present suffering.
You hear that? Like if all of that is coming,
if, if all of that is guaranteed, the things
that are in the future for us, all the magnitude of that
dwarfs present difficulties.
And listen, I know I'm not, I'm not denying reality here.
I know life can get very hard.
Even for some of you today, this Father's day thing,
it brings up a unique pain in your soul
for various reasons, whatever it is.
And today hurts.
I know life can get very hard
and as hard as life can be some days
it's not even close to how great it will be someday.
Like as low as it can get, as hard as it can get today,
tomorrow, next week, 10 years ago.
As hard as it can get.
It's not even on the same page, same wavelength as as good
as it will be someday in heaven.
So what Romans eight 18 reminds us of that the sufferings
of this present time are not worth comparing with the glory
that is to be revealed to us.
That's why this hope we're talking about is what compels
joy, that kind of hope.
'cause our hope is not doubtful, it's not fickle,
it's not feelings based.
Our hope is guaranteed by God's character
and God's promises to us.
And if what we hope for is infinitely valuable
and absolutely certain,
then present joy is not just possible.
It is actually rational.
Like if that's what we have coming for us, if that's
what God is giving us, it's possible and rational to praise
and rejoice today that
that future will be far better than this today.
Why wouldn't we be joyful?
Listen, to not rejoice in that kind of hope
would be to doubt either its value or it's certainty.
Like if it's rational to, to joy, have joy
and rejoice in it, to not rejoice would then be we're
doubting its value or we're doubting its certainty,
then maybe it's not really gonna happen.
Maybe God didn't guarantee it
or maybe you don't see the future
resurrection in Christ as that big a deal.
Of course you're not gonna rejoice if you don't believe it's
gonna happen or if it's like
that's not that big a deal to me.
Of course you won't rejoice in it today.
Or maybe, maybe you don't see heaven and see righteousness
and, and even the fact that you'll see Jesus face to face.
Maybe you don't see that as actually more valuable than
what we have here today.
Well then of course you're not gonna rejoice in what's
coming because it's not that much better, if any.
You see how tragic that is that we see this
as more valuable than what God is offering us in the future.
That's tragic.
That's why joy, it it it's almost a sense of an act
of faith in God's promises.
'cause you have to look past this stuff right here.
You have to look past good
and bad here to see something future.
And so you have to, in a sense, act of faith, choose to say,
okay, God, I I know you're bringing all this stuff.
I know you're bringing all these things.
And so God, I choose joy to
rejoice in that certain hope.
I'm not just choosing joy in spite of things.
I'm choosing joy in that in you. That's coming.
I you've seen it too in your life.
But I, I watch friends lose a spouse or
or lose children or get a cancer diagnosis
or lose a job
and it astounds me every single time I'll,
I'll have a conversation with them personally
or they'll stand here on this stage at a funeral speaking
and I'll hear them say things like,
it hurts deeper than anything I've ever hurt before.
It's to my core. I'll never get over it. Yes.
But my hope is Jesus, I can continue
because of Jesus and listen that I mean it.
It is overwhelming to me to watch that happen, to hear
that happen when somebody who has gone
through the hardest moment,
the worst thing you can ever imagine,
and they're staying, they're still saying, my hope is Jesus.
My hope is Jesus. Listen,
that's maturity in Christ.
That's not being wavered by the winds of life and the world.
It's not being swayed by anything. It's confident assurance.
That is one of the main markers of mature Christian living
that is maturity in Christ to to rejoice in hope
through pain, to have
joy in the midst of dark chaos all around you.
That that's a marker of mature Christian living.
Because listen, how much easier is it? We all know this.
How much easier is it to look at our present circumstances
for measures of joy and happiness, right?
We look at how we feel that day
or how things are going in our
lives or whatever it is, right?
We we do that. We all do that. And it's easy.
It's a lot easier to do that than it is to look
for the unseen future promises of God,
to find our hope there.
It's easier to try to find it here than it is
to find it there.
But mature believers in Christ have learned how
to find their joy in unseen realities,
in the guarantee of resurrection of the future,
in the guarantee of their glorification in the future,
in the inheritance that they're gonna get in heaven
that's kept for them there in the new heavens
and new earth where there'll be no more
pain and sorrow and suffering.
They, they know that's coming.
That's where they find their joy. That's maturity.
And so I'm talking to these people trying
to discern like how, how do you get there?
And the thing I keep hearing over
and over again is that it's not automatic.
You don't just wake up one day and find that hope
whenever the the world comes crashing down on you.
It's not automatic. This kind of Romans 12 rejoicing
and hope is not automatic.
It requires intentional focus
and discipline to remind yourselves
of all these truths every day.
Not just when you hit the worst moments To remind
and discipline yourself over and over
and over, recalling to your heart daily, these things
that we possess in Christ.
We're preaching the gospel to ourselves every day reminding
ourselves that Jesus lived, died, resurrected, ascended,
and he's coming back one day to fix all this mess.
We keep preaching ourselves that message
and that he did all of that.
He gave us graciously,
gave us all these things I just described,
the substance of our hope.
He gave us all of that. Why?
Because he loves us more than we can ever imagine.
And you keep preaching yourself
that message till it sinks down into your heart.
That is what grows your maturity.
It's what grows your joy in the Lord
and hope in the future.
But lemme give you a picture of what the enemy wants to do
to you in that process.
The enemy of your soul trying to derail all of that.
What does he try to do? What's his?
What's one of his main ways to come at you in this process?
Here's what he does. He tempts you
to focus on present problems
rather than future glory.
He want to get, he wants to get your eyes on all
of the mess, all the problems you're facing at school
or at work or at home or financially.
He's like, look at your health.
He wants you to focus on the present problems rather than
looking at future glory.
But when I think of that, it makes me think of Paul
and Silas in the book of Acts.
Paul and Silas were in prison
and don't think prison today like nasty dungeon like prison
probably in stocks where their hands
and feet were through pieces
of wood that they couldn't move.
And yet what were they doing? They're singing hymns.
They're praying boldly, loudly.
They're joy filled believers in the midst of one
of the worst situations you can ever imagine.
You know what that tells me? That they had cultivated,
they had fought for joy for years and years in Christ.
They had trained their minds
and their hearts to fight for joy in the Lord beyond
what they could see in the moment.
They knew something future was better than this.
So in the moment they could react with joy, not
with getting crushed by their circumstances.
Here's what happens when you do that though.
It happens for Paul and Silas.
But here's what for you and me when we do that,
when we fight for joy, here's what that kind
of joy actually does.
It demonstrates the supernatural nature
and power of the gospel.
'cause that's not natural, that's not normal,
that's not innate to us in our flesh.
For us to rejoice in hope, in the midst of the pain
and suffering of the world.
That's not natural. We wanna go hide.
We wanna go crawl in the corner and give up.
That's natural to us.
What's supernatural is the power of God working through us.
It shows the world something
that is not dependent on our circumstances.
That when your family is falling apart,
yet you have a steady faith through it
that shines pretty bright in a world it's dark
When you lose your job, yet the temperature of your soul
burns hot for Jesus in the midst of all of that, that is
standing out in a dark world
when your peer group at school sets you aside
because you are not going to participate in the same things
that they participate in.
Yet you still walk with a humble confidence in the Lord,
your head held, held high
because your identities in Christ, not in
what everybody else says about you.
And that is what stands out in the world.
Because that's only God
like this kind of joy here.
See this today, this kind of joy is an evangelistic witness
to the glory and goodness of our God.
It shines bright.
'cause the world is very dark, very, very much
anti true joy.
It's gotta be good conditions.
It's gotta be good circumstances. This is evangelistic.
When we have joy, your hope filled joy, no matter
what you face in life, becomes a beacon
that points other people to our God.
That's why one of our, a few years ago we did this
as a church, one of our new values is
what we call life giving hope.
One of the things that we have a goal of as a church is
that we are going to reflect the gospel of Jesus Christ
with delight by building relationships
and environments infused with grace and joy.
That that we want this place to be a yes, it exciting we,
we want people to, to feel good about being around here,
but, but what we want more is that God would show through us
that there is a deep root of joy
because of the hope we have in him.
That when everything falls apart, when our lives crumble
and everything looks horrible, that people look at us
as a church and they're like,
what's different about you guys?
There's a life there that nobody else
Has.
What is it? It's hope, it's
Joy, it the Lord as our Strength.
So how do we cultivate that? Right?
Well, that's what we want.
Again, most of us walked in here, probably not full board,
a hundred percent joy on this.
So, so how do we cultivate that?
How do you, how do you
and I mature into this kind of hope filled
rejoicing person as a follower of Christ?
Well, it's not really that complicated.
I'm not saying it's easy, but it's not complicated.
Just a couple examples.
Start by meditating regularly on the promises
of God in scripture.
Like you heard me just a few minutes ago,
the passages I shared about our future inheritance,
about our glorification, about the future, resurrection,
about these promises of God and what he's done
and what he will do.
Just take those in, soak them into your,
your soul regularly.
Just go over 'em over and over like again and again. Again.
Keep preaching those to you every single
day moment by moment.
Memorize them so you don't forget.
These are the things God has promised. Hold onto those.
He's proven himself to be trustworthy. I can.
So I'm going to trust him for the future.
So meditate on his word. Second, look to Christ's example.
Look to Christ.
One of my favorite verses is Hebrews 12, verse two.
It says, for the joy set
before him, he endured the cross despising the shame
for the joy.
Now, now think about that He endured
beyond our imagination the worst thing possible.
Now we know like, oh, the the nails and the spear
and the crown of thorns like that must've been pretty bad.
We can imagine that this was, you amp it up
with all the spiritual stuff going on on the cross.
Jesus endured immense suffering. Why?
Because he focused on the hope
of glorifying his father
and doing everything necessary
to redeem sinners like you and me.
He went to that extent.
He went through the suffering with joy
because he knew what was coming on the other side.
He knew his father would be glorified
and he knew that sinners would be saved by doing this.
So he said, I'm doing it. I'm willing. Like I love it.
I love those people enough. I'm gonna do this.
That's joy, right? With joy.
He endured the cross
'cause he knew what was coming on the other side.
So look to Christ like, look to this example of what he did
for us and say, man, I, if he's in me now, I can do that.
I can endure whatever I need to endure
because I know what's coming on the other side.
And it's better than what this is. So meditate on his word.
Look to Christ. Here's a, here's another way
to cultivate this hope, this joy.
It's by fellowshipping with other believers
who share this same hope.
Like this is why church is so important, not legalistic,
that you just have to be here every Sunday.
Check a box. Like no, like I, I had a conversation
with a man before the first service today.
Hadn't seen him in a while. He lost his wife just recently.
And he teared up as I was talking to him.
And you know what I was thinking about this
and I was like, brother, listen, you need me
to carry you right now, don't you?
But then I looked him in the eye and I was like,
there's some day coming that I'm gonna need you to carry me,
to give me a sense of hope that I don't have right now,
that, that I'm doing for you right now
or you're gonna do that for me someday.
That that's what Hebrews 10 explains to us. Watch this.
Hebrews 10, 19 through 25, look at how this,
this draws us into the glory of the gospel.
It says, therefore brothers, since we have confidence
to enter the holy places by the blood of Jesus, by the new
and living way that he opened for us through the curtain,
that is through his flesh,
since we have a great high priest over the house of God.
Meaning because God has done what he's done
because Jesus did what he did.
Verse 22, let us draw near, near to God
with a true heart in full assurance of faith
with our heart sprinkled clean from an evil conscious,
our bodies washed with pure water like assurance of faith.
God's done when he's done. So I have access to God.
Now, praise that verse 23.
So let us hold fast the confession of our hope
without wavering.
For he who promised is faithful.
We have hope we can hold fast to it because God is faithful.
But then look next 24
and let us consider how to stir up one another
to love and good works.
Not neglecting to meet together as is the habit of some,
but encouraging one another
and all the more as you see the day drawing here,
encourage, give courage to one another
whenever it is hard to see a way out, when it's hard
to hold fast to that confession of our hope.
It says give courage. Give courage.
Give courage to each other.
Sit there and have hope
for someone who doesn't have hope right now.
Encourage, lift them up, grab them by the shoulders
and say, come on, I'm gonna pull the rope for you.
Let's go because we're looking forward. Do you see that?
We're looking forward to the day Jesus comes back and,
and all this isn't the way it is anymore.
It's not the way it is right now. It's gonna be different.
It's gonna be future, it's gonna be glory that
all his promises will come to pass fully.
And finally, let's go.
Like let's keep going together towards that.
We need each other.
Listen, if you pursue this meditation on scripture,
if you look to Christ, if you band together the believers,
share the hope, you will mature in your ability
to rejoice in hope.
It will grow in your hearts.
So remember this command to rejoice in hope is grounded,
not in circumstances grounded in the certainty of
who God is, of what He's done and what he will do.
And because of that content are rejoicing, is reasonable,
it's normal, it's expected.
This is what we do
because of what we have coming, what he's done,
what he is doing and what he's going to do.
We should normally rejoice
and pour out our praise to who he is.
That, that, that lifestyle, listen, is not just an emotion,
it is hope and faith.
Married together, steadfastly believing that God will do
what he promised he's gonna do.
That's maturity. No matter
what the world circumstances life looks like,
I know he will do what he said he's gonna do.
That's maturity in Christ.
You remember the scene where Jesus invited Peter
to walk on the water with him?
It's Matthew 14. There's a couple other places it's
recorded, but, but listen, I love that scene
because we already know
that Jesus can walk on the water, right?
Like he's God in the flesh.
So of course waves all this, he's walking on the water.
That's just what God does.
Peter though, that guy, like the one
who stuck his foot in his mouth over to us,
spotted off on all these like cutting
dude's ear off like that guy.
Yeah. Because God empowered him to do it.
Jesus invited him out.
So Peter steps outta the boat
and he's walking on the water just like Jesus, all
because God empowered him to do it for God's glory.
It wasn't anything in Peter,
he had nothing to bring to the table.
He just said, okay. And he walks.
But as Peter stepped outta the boat
as he was walking on the water,
like you can imagine Peter's own mind,
like I'm wa I'm on the water.
Like and other people watching him from the boat like this
is Peter walking like,
but as he was on the water walking, drawing nearer to Jesus,
verse 30 of Matthew 14 says, when Peter
saw the wind, he was afraid.
What that means is he took his eyes off of Jesus
and he started looking at the storm.
What happened then? He began to sink, right?
He needed Jesus to reach down and rescue him.
And I and I read that story and,
and we're all like, man Peter, come on.
You just keep looking at Jesus. Isn't it really easy for us
to take our eyes off of Jesus when the storms
of life crash on us too to, And we look down
and we see the world and we see this storm
and we, we look around
and instead of looking to Jesus, we look at all of this.
But that is the last thing we need to do.
That's the last thing we should
do in the middle of the storm.
We've got to focus harder.
We've gotta look more at Him, more at Jesus instead
of the storm reminding ourselves of what's true, of
what he's given us, of what is certain
of the hope that has succumbed.
We must look at him instead of looking at the world.
That is the essence of the Christian faith.
It is this convinced nature that we are so convinced
of the future grace of God that we can rejoice.
Now, regardless of what present circumstances may say,
may show this is what we can do.
We can rejoice in him
because of what he's going to do, proven by
what he has done.
It's a confidence that acknowledges the pain.
But it says to the pain, you are not ultimately going to win
because of what's coming.
Here's the greatest tragedy.
The greatest tragedy is not that our lives are hard.
The greatest tragedy is that Christians act
as if we've forgotten this magnitude of this hope.
Right? You, you see that the greatest tragedy is
not that our lives are hard.
The greatest tragedy is that Christians live
as though we have forgotten the magnitude
of the hope we have in the future, proven by
what He's done in the past, proven by
what he's doing right now.
That we should not forget that we got to be a people
so grounded in the certainty of God's promises.
That the world looks at us
and asks the question, why do you have the hope you have
when the world falls apart?
When your life falls apart,
when everything seems like it's dark and you stand up
and say, I've got hope in the Lord.
He is how I stand. The world looks at it and says, why?
And so let's pray towards that, that joy is not natural.
And so we need to ask God for it right now.
So Lord, we do come to you humbly And we pray that in light
of this joy, this hope, this certainty, Lord, that
that we don't naturally have
that it is a fruit of your spirit.
So God, we need you in your spirit right now to, to
awaken our hearts if needed, to stir our affections for you.
That we would not walk out
of here without a more certain future.
That no matter what we see on the news, no matter
what we see at work, no matter what we feel at school,
that there's a certainty that hope is coming.
You are our hope. We have past, present, future hope.
You are all that we need.
And we have joy today because of all of that.
Lord, remind us of that.
Stir our affections for you, that we would walk in joy,
we would walk in hope, we would walk
with a different cadence,
a different confidence because of who you are.
Thank you, God. Listen, church, if you don't feel that,
let this be sung over you.
Let's remind one another
of this hope we have in Christ if you're able
to stand together and sing.
Enjoy today.